6 22 it is good day Las Vegas you know
three leading home improvement trade
shows back in Las Vegas this week if
you've noticed the convention center the
World Market Center are jammed it's a
chance to see some new ways to spruce up
your house we love Dr Frank we love
having you here on the show and you've
got some really cool now these are not
little gadgets these are Big gadgets we
try to get them in but they're so big
but we brought videos so our audience
can basically that'll show it so let's
start you got a front door refrigerator
French door refrigerator yes this is by
Signature Kitchen Suite it's a 48 inch
Believe It or Not 48 inch but what they
did they did a survey by one poll and
found that what's most important is
space in the kitchen and 50 of the
Americans that were pulled want an extra
large fridges right okay so what
Signature Kitchen Suite did is they
brought up the 48 inch built-in French
door refrigerator spacious capacity
preservation technology for food
freshness and smart organization and
it's very versatile the width interior
you have lifting
isn't that great and the other thing
that's really cool what I love about it
is that you basically have door bins LED
lighting and panel ready so you can
either get it in stainless steel as you
see or you can actually put a custom
panel on oh nice okay A lot of people do
that yeah
right and that fits in with what you're
talking about if the trade show is going
on right now is the idea of size people
want if they can fit it in their homes
more room for more things whether it's
fridges whether it's washing their
clothes oh yeah they want more room oh
yeah and absolutely next is the LG
washer what I love about this it's
basically a watchtower okay and what's
interesting and people want more
capacity they want to put more things in
it but they don't want a bigger
footprint yeah so right so what LG did
is this is great and the control panel
is in the center which makes so much
sense because you can easily easily
reach it which I love so much and what's
interesting you know it basically does
quite a bit it has optimal washing
performance it detects load size fabric
softness and soil level okay it has
smart pairing it allows a wash sure to
tell the dryer the right compatible
drying cycle during the process isn't
that amazing yeah and the drying prep
feature preheats the dryer even before
the washing cycle is over so smart is it
amazing well you think the washer dryer
right next to each other they should be
best friends they should talk to each
other and they are the certified by the
way by asthma analogy it's Asthma and
Allergy friendly so their allergen cycle
removes 95 of a common household
allergens and LG's thin Q care which is
they're basically they're they're
basically platform provides Optimal
Performance with useful tips and guides
ah such smart stuff okay Dr Frank we got
a less than a minute left so I know
you've got some some smart home devices
too yeah absolutely no this is by nice
the company is called nice right and the
benefit here is they're talking to
builders and Builders are saying you
know our customers want everything they
want to move in with everything in the
home security audio video lighting and
so forth so this is great so this is
their booth at the show and basically
they won an award from CTA the consumer
technology Association and the mark of
options for their Builder services so
what they've done is they've taken
programs for a production type home
luxury homes and multi-family homes and
the benefit here is that smart home has
control and automation for everything so
you've got audio video sun shades and
security as well and there's access with
a nice linear garage gate and by the way
linear you guys have one of those at the
front door well I've got in this one oh
it's made by linear look at that which
is by nice and of course go to
niceforyou.com and you get the the
builders have a whole package as well
it's getting to the point where like
we're not living with the house the
house is living with us so they're so
smart
these are by smart they're smart home
appliances by sharp and sharp has the
latest basically they take Wi-Fi and
Wi-Fi as you know is really runs
everything in the home today yeah you
have to have it but basically the
benefit here they have a slide in smart
dishwasher that allows you basically
with the move of the hand called
adjuster control right just to control
everything no control yeah and our video
will show
yeah so you basically can you can talk
to it and tell it you want it to turn on
and you can also wave your hand and
makes it work so this gives you an idea
this is their drop-in gas range yeah
absolutely so good stuff there's a lot
going on here at these at these trade
shows a lot of smart things to have in
our homes Dr Frank we appreciate you
joining us once again this morning such
Cool Tech huh I know we can talk to you
for hours unfortunately once all we can
so Dr Frank all the good stuff we can
put it on our website too of course all
right stay with us